I got a little vod-sod in my thing.
-Oh, I was wondering how it got refilled, I was like why is she being so slow with her drink. -Oh no
I just did a new, a little tiny vod-sod in the same glass.
-Oh good, we're recording.
-Oh, thank god.
You guys just got a real slice of life.
If you wondered what it's like hanging out with Mamrie and I off camera, it's exactly that.
*Opening noises*
Hi guys! My name is Grace Helbig. If you don't know, now you know, your life is different now.
-So different.
-I'm here with Mamrie Hart *crashing noise*
-Cheers! -Cheers! *clink*
Hurray! -Cue the "why do you do that" comment.
-We shot a video on Mamrie's channel, a Q and Rosé, where we answered some of your most burning questions and drank Rosé.
-It's a brilliant concept.
-I got into a K-hole of Logan Paul videos today, and I found out that he released a new song a few days ago called "The Second Verse".
-I didn't know he had a first verse; I didn't know Logan Paul sang.
-I know very minimal things about this video, so I thought it would be really fun for Mamrie and I to react to the video, but to turn it into more of a game because
this is not us sh*ting on this at all, what so ever. -No
-We wanted to make it a game for ourselves, so I thought we would come up with five different things, each of us, that we think might happen at some point
during this music video and if they do, we get points. And by the end of the video, whoever has guessed the most amount of things, wins
-Question. -Okay
-I'm gonna test how much you already know about this. -Okay.
-Does Logan Paul sing or rap? Because he looks like a white boy who would rap. -I don't...
So here is all I know about this video, just so we're on the same page and it doesn't look like I'm cheating.
Because this is obviously a game I need to win to make my life feel full. So..
His brother, Jake Paul, and him have had public beef lately. -What!?
-I know.
-Also, we should open a butcher called that. Private beef! -I only have private beef. -My beefs are private. -I only have private beef.
-Uh, reporting for duty private beef.
-I guess they've been going back and forth, like publicly kinda shaming each other.
Jake Paul posted a billboard of an unflattering photo of Logan to promote his merch.
-That's funny. -Yeah. And so this is Logan's response to him doing that.
And the only other thing I know in this is that when I googled it, what came up is a headline is that
Jake Paul's ex girlfriend is in this video with Logan Paul. -Woah.
-Yeah. And she's like, she said some stuff about her relationship with Jake, that he like cheated on her all the time and stuff.
She posted like an expose video kind of thing. -*Gasp*
So she shows up at some point in this, and that's basically all I know.
So now, we have to write five things that we think might happen, based on that shallow knowledge of this video and Logan himself,
and see, see what we come up with.
-Are we sharing them with each other or is it private? -Yeah.
-We're gonna, I'm gonna turn the camera off, we're gonna come up with five, and then we'll come back and share what each other have written and then we'll watch the video.
-Perfect! -Okay.
And we're back! So, we've written down our five things that we think might happen during this music video, let's start sharing them.
-Okay, read one.
-Mine is "someone with an accent raps".
-Oooh that's a good one! -Yeah, someone with a non American accent. -Oh. -Yeah.
-I say "Logan winks directly to camera".
-Oooh! I said "Logan is shirtless".
-I say "slow mo running chase sequence".
-I said "someone sits on a car in slow motion".
-Oh, "a slap across the face".
-Oh, that's a good one. I said "close up of a girl's butt in a bathing suit".
-I said "hoverboard chase", I'm going for two chases.
-And I said "there's an animal you'd regularly see at the zoo featured".
-And my last one is "Logan in drag".
-K well, let's see, uh, let's see what happens.
Uh, we'll see who, I mean the good thing is we don't have any of the same ones. -No, none of them.
-Okay, so this is gonna be a real experiment. -Okay if you get it right, you put it on your head.
-Put it on your head. -Put the sticky note on your head.
-Okay, here we go. -He's 22? -Yes ma'am.
-I'm really nervous. -Yeah, I know.
Video: What's up y'all on the vlog
Hey, uh -with my cup *inaudible* vlog footage
*old lady music* No, I just wanna see the music video
Wait, where's the music video?
Wait what?
What is this?
Hold on, it is on?
Is this his vlog? This is his vlog.
Watch the full song.
What the hell is happening?
That's the fall song -Wait, so what's..
but this is..from a couple days ago.
So this is..oh this is, this is the one.
Just your two moms
We are 90 years old.
Ignore the beginning. It's called the fall of Jake Paul.
Here we go.
(hey Jake)
(I made one phone call)
(I got the same house as you)
(Same cars too, it's really not that hard)
(Oh hey by the way, welcome to the top little brother)
(Feels good huh?)
(But let's not forget how you got here)
I don't..I...??
I don't know...I can't
*anticipation*
They cut right before.
Wow
Join the strongest family on the internet.
Physically maybe, they're very in shape.
Well, this didn't go as planned.
I got one.
And I go maybe someone sits in a car in slow motion that I missed,
I couldn't tell, there were a lot of jittery things happening.
Yeah couldn't tell if they were just slow
Or slowmo -And also that doge in the beginning could have been a zoo animal.
No one knows.
Was he in drag?
Ah I mean he was in his own merch.
It was a drag.
It was, no hate, it was very impressive the empire.
No don't come for me. Don't come for me Pauls.
I'll keep my raps to Audible.com plugs.
I drank, I chugged my drink because I felt so uncomfortable.
Why don't we just -I'm nervous for their finances
that they're spending this much money.
But also like they only give their friends 10%
so, maybe not that much.
Okay good for you.
I hope at least they got something out of it, I hope she got one of those cars.
You know who she looks exactly like?
A cross between Kylie Jenner and Kim Zolciak's oldest -daughter
Yep.
Well that's pretty uh
symbolic.
Oh Grace I'm so sorry this didn't work.
No it's okay, I think this was an educational experience and look
there's no guarantees in the ideas that you have.
There's also no guarantees in your career so please
respect your finances.
And surround yourself with good people. -Logan
Mamrie and I are going to work on our roast rap of Hannah Hart.
Ooooh lets start a feud!
The new YouTube challenge. -We need clickbait.
We need feuds.
We need possible affairs.
We need
views.
Yeah -That's our rap that just roasted ourselves.
Yeah, you ain't gotta roast us, we're already overcooked.
Yeah, we've been in that oven way too long
don't worry, we're burnt.
I hope you guys enjoyed this video.
If you did give it a thumbs up 'cos I make videos inconsistently.
Maybe that's why I
You make them so consistent Grace, you don't roast
we're going to do the opposite of a roast, we're going to build each other up.
I'm like trying to defend you from yourself.
Go over to Mamrie's channel and check out us answering some of your
burning questions because it got real over there.
It did get real.
Not as real as that
I mean like their Thanksgiving
is gonna be rough.
Ok, I'm exhausted. - Me too
I don't know.
I bet Grandma's face goes in the mash potatoes.
*gasp*
That's -I'm going ahead and calling it
Yeah and then they start selling mashed potatoes as
Grandma Logan
Grandma Paul's mashed potato face
She comes out of it like Mrs. Doubtfire
Hellooo